[Laughter]  [Music]  video of the confrontation shared on  Facebook now seen by over two million  people I'm doing your restaurant is not  doing its job because if she's positive  that she's seen us after an hour into  their meal  Alexis Bryson and a friend say they were  approached by a police officer in  Applebee's manager and a mall security  guard that's when they were accused of  dining and dashing a day before and the  video they repeatedly denied we have not  been backlash on social media was Swift  in Applebee's launched its own  investigation days later Appleby says  the franchise terminated the manager  server and another employee involved in  the incident back to that video you can  hear the officer finally allow the two  women to leave but first they had to pay  for that unfinished meal what they're  telling me is is that they want you to  go ahead and pay your bill and leave and  not come back okay that's perfect